I had found these two a octogenes a man
or woman in their 80s who were willing
to be naked and [__] on a couch when
people walked in
so I had this all set up in my buddy's
apartment he was going to walk in and
the old dude was going to be having sex
with her on the couch and he was going
to be wearing my buddy's favorite
baseball hat backwards
[Applause]
what happened I needed the okay from the
guy's girlfriend she pulled out
probably 36 hours before the prank and I
was like why and she goes that's his
favorite couch
hit a different couch and I was like put
a towel down she was like would that
make it better for you and I was like
nah
you're right I want a new couch too yeah
I don't need that